en effet les auditions se sont
poursuivies toute la journée une
information judiciaire pour homicide
volontaire par conjoint devrait même
être ouverte dans la soirée contre la
principale suspecte les pousses de la
victime âgée de 75 ans elle encourt la
réclusion à perpétuité
sa garde à vue a été maintenue c'est
elle qui avait déclaré être l'auteur des
tirs mortels à l'encontre de son mari
âgé de 82 ans dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche à l'aide d'un fusil de chasse
c'est la fille du couple qui avait fait
la macabre découverte quelques heures
après les faits prévenu par sa mère
c'est au lieu-dit champs-romain dans
cette petite maison au domicile familial
que les faits se sont déroulé une petite
maison qui jouxte un château surplombant
un coin de campagne où ce couple de
retraités son histoire s'était installée
il y a une dizaine d'années nous at on
dit en mairie un rapidement évoqué l la
thèse du drame familial a été confirmée
par le parquet de nevers qui souhaite
maintenant définir s'il y avait ou non
préméditation